This is a story of success.
Amongst the hundreds of thousands of Central
Europeans who left Europe to go to America
in search of a better life, many are those
who found out that America’s promises were
vacuous, many managed to establish a decent
living and some achieved spectacular successes,
demonstrating that this was the right country
to welcome a young immigrant with the right
work ethic, unique talents and a sharp business
acumen.
This is the story of the success of a Hungarian
boy who went to America and became one of
the most successful entertainers of all times,
known as the Master of the Escape.
He was, of course, Harry Houdini – acrobat,
contortionist, magician, escape artist, entrepreneur,
film tycoon, debunker of occultists, maybe
even a secret agent …???
Above all, Harry Houdini was a master marketer
and manager of his own public image, using
a variety of media to promote his shows and
his famous stunts that would defy Death and
leave it empty handed every time.
Please welcome Harry Houdini, the closest
America ever got to having a real life superhero.
Erik
Our hero was born on the 24th of March 1874
in Budapest, Austro-Hungarian Empire, with
the name of Erik Weisz.
[Pronounced as ‘Vice’]
He was one of seven children born to Samuel
and Cecilia, who had married in 1863.
Samuel [TA1] had started in life as a soapmaker
and he certainly had intellectual ambitions:
he graduated as a Doctor in Law and had also
studied to become a Rabbi and Bible scholar,
eventually becoming a civil servant in Budapest.
His career must have hit a hard stop, though,
as the Weisz family was forced to emigrate
to the USA in 1887, in search of fortune and
a better life.
This ‘hard stop’ according to some sources,
was an event worthy of a novel by Alexandre
Dumas, father of the Three Musketeers.
It seems that Samuel had challenged – and
killed – in a duel an Austro-Hungarian nobleman,
known only as ‘Erich’.
To prevent prosecution, he had to organise
an escape to America [TA2] with the help of
a good friend called Carl Herman, whom you
may find amusing to know, was at that time
one of the most famous stage magicians in
Europe.
It is foreshadowing, to say the least, that
the early life of he who would become Harry
Houdini were to be influenced by an escape
aided by a stage magician.
This version of the events may be corroborated
by the fact that according to other sources,
Samuel first left alone for the States[TA3]
, followed by the rest of the family at a
later stage.
Whatever the reasons for this escape, or emigration,
the Weisz had their surname changed to ‘Weiss’
in Ellis Island.
The ever-creative immigration officers also
re-christened young Erik as ‘Ehrich’.
Ehrich[TA4]
Young Ehrich and his family initially lived
between Appleton and Milwaukee, in Wisconsin.
Ehrich demonstrated from a very early age
a talent for athleticism, becoming very early
a proficient runner, swimmer and amateur boxer.
A History Channel mini-series, aired in 2014
portrayed Ehrich’s relationship with his
father as fractured and dysfunctional.
In reality, Ehrich was very closed to Samuel,
who encouraged Ehrich’s early interest in
acrobatics and stage magic by taking him to
Circus and Carnival shows.
In 1883 in fact Ehrich started his career
as a performer, becoming a contortionist.
He was able to perform feats such as bending
over backwards in a ‘bridge’ position
to pick up a pin from the floor with his teeth.
He also learned very early how to dislocate
shoulders, or other joints, from their sockets
in order to increase his flexibility.
These early displays of stagecraft were absolutely
not opposed by Samuel and Cecilia.
The Weisses found it difficult to make a living:
Samuel’s career as a Rabbi had not fully
picked up since the move to America, and any
job that Ehrich and his siblings could pick
up were very welcome to the family finances.
This was demonstrated by a sad event.
On Christmas Eve 1885, the oldest of the Weiss
siblings, Herman, died of tuberculosis at
the age of 22.
And it was Ehrich who paid for the funeral
expenses, thanks to his earnings as a performer.
When Ehrich turned 13 he and Samuel moved
to New York.
It was here that the pre-teen added acrobatics
to his talents, performing as a trapeze artist
with stage names such as ‘Prince Erik’
or ‘The Prince of the Air’
[TA5] During the same period young Ehrich
would pick up another talent that would become
key to his later career.
He became the apprentice of a locksmith, a
line of work which made him become fascinated
with locks of any kind – and also how to
pick them open.
It is reported that he developed such skills
that he stunned his employer in at least two
occasions: like that time when he managed
to open a pair of handcuffs using only a piece
of piano wire; or when he unlocked all the
doors to all the shops in his street … just
for the hell of it!
With the combination of these talents - acrobatics,
contortionism, lock-picking - Ehrich could
have easily gone into becoming a burglar.
And who knows, I may have been here anyways
talking about how he had pulled the most successful
heist in History.
But luckily, he soon found another career
to channel his talents, surely more honest
but by any means no less risky.
Harry
At the age of seventeen Ehrich and his brother
Theo worked on developing a magical act[TA6]
, which they would perform at so called ‘Penny
Circuses’, music halls, sideshows and at
New York’s Coney Island amusement park.
As they grew in popularity Ehrich thought
it wise they chose a stage name.
Ehrich and Theo used to call each other ‘Harry’
and ‘Dash’.
So, first names sorted.
As per the last name, Harry went for ‘Houdini’,
after one of his idols, French illusionist
Robert Houdin.
[Who-dan]
The Houdini Brothers would perform up to 20
shows every single day.
Their partnership continued until in 1894
they met another entertainer, teenage singer
and dancer Wilhelmina Beatrice Rahner, better
known as Bess.
At that time, Bess was part of an act called
“The Floral Sisters” and had initially
started dating ‘Dash’, but after she and
Harry met they were smitten with each other.
It was a real coup de foudre.
Harry and Bess courted, got engaged and married
in the span of one week!
In addition to be life partners they also
became partners on stage, as Bess replaced
Dash as Harry’s sidekick.
So, at this point of the story we should really
feel sorry for Dash Houdini aka Theo Weiss.
The poor guy has been basically pushed to
the side twice by his brother, romantically
and professionally.
No wonder then, that the two would develop
a bitter rivalry, right?
Well, wrong again.
But I am not going to leap ahead like a trapeze
artist now, so I am going to stick to Bess
and Harry’s love story.
Bess
Bess and Harry remained deeply in love for
the rest of their lives – and maybe even
after.
Harry gave her credit for many of his achievements
and developed the habit of writing her a love
letter every single day.
Sometimes, when they were on tour, Harry would
write her a letter even when sitting in the
same hotel room.
It is widely reported that the couple was
largely faithful to each other, despite the
temptations that a famous magician may incur
when meeting his fans.
Well actually Harry did not stick 100% to
his marital vows: he had at least one confirmed
and documented affair with a lady called Charmian
London, wife of famous novelist Jack London.
Bess, on the other hand, was much more serious.
Only on one occasion, to make Harry jealous,
she sat on a lap of a young Colonel at a party.
The ruse worked: Houdini, the man who would
defy death thousands of times on and off stage,
was terrified at the sight of his wife sitting
on some other guy’s lap.
For months afterwards, the mere mention of
the word ‘Colonel’ would get him into
a funk.
In 1895, the Houdinis joined the Welsh Brothers
Circus for six months.
Harry performed his magic tricks while Bess
sang and danced.
Together they devised an illusion called "Metamorphosis",
in which they switched places in a locked
trunk, as fast as the bat of an eyelid.
Over the same period Harry and Bess wowed
audiences by performing as spiritualists on
stage – in other words acting as mediums
to summon the spirits of the dead.
It was all an act, of course, but performed
very convincingly: Harry apparently got Bess
into a trance and then the spirits would use
her as a mouthpiece to communicate with the
living.
Harry’s favourite approach was to ask the
spirits about recent unsolved murders in the
town they were performing.
It is said that on one occasion one of such
spirits revealed the identity of a murderer.
The man, who was sitting among the audience,
jumped from his seat and fled the scene[TA7]
.
Was the story true, or just one of the many
publicity stunts that Harry would pull over
the years?
PR became one of the many skills Harry mastered,
alongside his most visible and memorable endeavour:
the art of escape.
The King of Handcuffs
When arriving in a new town, Houdini issued
a challenge to the local police department:
he would be able to escape from any handcuffs
provided by the local officers.
If he failed, he would offer a reward of $ 100.
As you may have guessed, he never had to pay.
This type of stunts would bring him increasing
attention from the press and free promotion
for his shows, to the point that he became
a headliner on the vaudeville circuit.
In 1899 Harry got his first big break.
A vaudeville impresario called Martin Beck
encouraged Houdini to focus his shows on escapes
– any type of escape from handcuffs, chains,
locks, trunks and shackles.
Beck also booked him on a tour of Europe,
which would be a turning point in the magician’s
career.
The following year Mr and Mrs Houdini sailed
to England for their first engagement in a
London theatre.
As ever, he insured his success with a clever
PR stunt: Houdini wowed audiences and ‘bobbies’
alike when he successfully broke free from
handcuffs placed on him by arguably the best
police department in the world, Scotland Yard.
According to authors William Kalush and Larry
Sloman, this stunt impressed the head of Scotland
Yard, William Melville who initiated Houdini
to his parallel, secret career: that of a
spy in His Majesty’s Service.
Was Houdini a spy?
The idea is so enticing that I want a mini-series,
right here, right now, about Houdini spying
on the French, the Russians, the Germans in
the years leading to WWI.
The claim is, after all, credible: as a famous
performer Harry would have been able to tour
all of Europe undisturbed and have access
to high ranking officials.
And if he ever got caught … good luck in
restraining him!
No, he wasn’t
However, the theory has been debunked by several
other authors.
First of all, the British Intelligence Service
was not established until 1909.
Then, by 1900 Houdini was not yet famous enough
to presume that he would be able to, say,
perform for the Kaiser or anything similar.
But the best counter argument comes from fellow
magician and professional debunker, the Great
James Randi.
“If Houdini had been a spy, that would have
gotten out.
He never would have been able to sit on it!”[TA8]
Let’s go on with the tour[TA9]
In November of 1900 Harry invited his brother
Dash [TA10] to join him in the rest of his
European tour.
Was this a reconciliation for the two brothers?
Actually, there was never a rift between them
and the two had always been and always remained
close friends and collaborators.
Harry had a plan: he had helped Dash in launching
his career as a magician and escape artist
with the stage name of Hardeen, which sounded
close enough to Houdini.
As Harry and Bess toured the European theatres,
Hardeen would follow suit and book performances
in venues that Harry didn’t play.
This was a scheme to shut out of the market
the many cheap imitators of Harry’s escape
art, at the same time raking in additional
revenue that would stay in the family.
The supposed rivalry was also part of the
ruse: the two brothers simply fed this fake
piece of news to the press, knowing very well
that this created even more free advertising
for their shows.
In at least one occasion Dash, Theo, Hardeen,
whatever you like to call him, even pioneered
an act that would become one of Harry’s
best-known routines: the strait jacket escape.
Meanwhile, the publicity from the Scotland
Yard escape had caused Houdini's fame to spread
across the Channel.
Sold-out engagements followed in Germany and
then across other European countries.
In addition to leaving police forces baffled,
Harry came up with another way to attract
attention: jumping into rivers, fully chained
and handcuffed.
With sadistic glee, Houdini would remain underwater
long after having removed his shackles, allowing
the suspense to build among the audience.
With his last remaining breath, he would then
emerge from under water waving triumphantly.
This was performance art, guerrilla marketing
and viral promotion all rolled into one.
Death defying acts[TA11]
In 1905 Harry and Bess returned to the United
States.
He had become an international celebrity by
now and the public were expecting increasingly
daring exploits from him.
And he satisfied them.
I already mentioned the strait-jacket act.
Harry was able to set himself free from such
a contraption thanks to his ability to self-dislocate
his shoulders from their sockets, in pure
Martin Riggs style
[Subtitle: If you got that reference, you
are too old for this sh*t]
But that was too easy, so Houdini would perform
the act while hanging upside down from a skyscraper
(!) in the cities he was touring in.
And not just any skyscraper.
As we have already established that the man
was a marketing and PR pioneer: so, he picked
buildings that housed major newspapers.
This ensured that photographers got the best
shots of him and The Great Houdini would make
the headlines.
Unsurprisingly, his shows were sold out.
His triumphant return to America was the setting
for the creation of increasingly outrageous
death-defying acts.
You have probably heard about, or seen images,
of the most famous ones.
For example, the milk can escape.
Houdini was shackled and lowered into an industrial
size milk can filled with water, and then
hidden behind a curtain.
Though he was usually able to escape in three
minutes, Harry frequently stayed behind the
curtain for up to a half hour, making his
re-appearance even more dramatic.
The milk can was the setting for one of his
rare failures: in one performance the can
was filled with beer, rather than water.
That sounds like great fun to you and me,
but Houdini was a tee-totaller and the effects
of alcohol knocked him out.
For once, he had to be pulled to safety by
his stage hands.
Another famous example was the act he called
‘Upside Down’, but which the press rebranded
as ‘Chinese Water Torture Chamber’.
Houdini would have his feet shackled, his
hands handcuffed and then would be placed
upside down inside a transparent tank filled
with water.
To increase the suspense, he sometimes invited
the audience to hold their breath for as long
as it took for him to emerge from the Chamber.
One less known, but much more bizarre stunt
was a one-off event that took place in September
1911 in Boston.
Some businessmen challenged Houdini to attempt
an escape from inside the carcass of a 1,500-pound
“sea monster” that had washed up in Boston’s
harbour.
It is not clear what the monster was, maybe
a whale or a giant leatherback turtle.
In any case, Houdini accepted the challenge.
In front of thousands of spectators Harry
was handcuffed, shackled and wedged inside
the stinking carcass.
Houdini emerged after 15 minutes – normally
he would have done with the irons much more
quickly, but he was nearly poisoned by the
chemicals used to embalm the monster.
He was by now one of the top celebrities in
America and for sure the most famous stage
magician slash master lock picker.
But there is more to life than just
stage magic
and picking
locks[TA12]
But there is more to life than just stage
magic and picking locks and Harry’s vivid
curiosity did not allow him to stagnate on
just one talent.
In the 1910s and early 1920s he sought to
diversify his activities, driven by patriotism,
love of adventure, love of justice or simply
to make a few extra bucks – which are all
perfectly fine motivations.
During a 2nd tour of Europe in 1909 Harry
had developed a love for aviation and had
bought a Voisin biplane, Made in France.
Interesting to note – he was one of the
first private pilots.
In March 1910 Houdini was touring Australia
and took three short flights with his Voisin,
near Melbourne.
This was certified at the time as the first
powered flight to take place Down Under, making
Harry Houdini a pioneer of aviation – plus
I am sure it got him some extra headlines
and ticket sales along the way.
[Subtitle: it was later discovered that he
had been beaten by a couple of months by a
British aviator, Colin Defries]
A few years later and back in the States,
Harry volunteered to serve the Government
in a time of need.
In April 1917 the US entered the War against
the Central Empires and although Houdini was
theoretically Austro-Hungarian, he was staunchly
loyal to his country of adoption.
In 1917 and 1918 he cancelled his tours to
entertain soldiers instead, and to raise money
for the war effort.
He even organised some lessons for the troops,
where he taught them how to free themselves
if they were made captive by the Germans.
Not all his extra-magician activities were
successful, though.
Between 1919 and 1923 Houdini tried his hand
at movie stardom.
He was the lead in “The Master Mystery”,
before deciding to create his own production
company with the help of Dash.
The Houdini Picture Corporation released “The
Man from Beyond” and “Haldane of the Secret
Service”.
The latter two films tanked at the box office.
It seems like Harry, after all, could fail,
too.
Anyways, by the beginning of the 1920s Houdini
had other preoccupations on his mind.
This is when he started a parallel career
as debunker [TA13] of occultist, spiritualists
and mediums.
In general, he would expose as fakes anybody
who claimed to communicate with the dead – which
is ironic given his early performances.
What Houdini could not tolerate was the exploitation
of well-meaning individuals, willing to communicate
with their deceased loved ones.
He campaigned with fervour, often visiting
séances in disguise to expose their ringleader
as frauds.
When he could not go in person, he sent one
of his team of detectives who would go to
seances on his behalf and bring back information
… information which allowed him to set up
shows entirely dedicated to exposing the tricks
used by the fake mediums.
Houdini offered a $10,000 reward to any psychic
who could present “physical phenomena”
that could not be explained rationally.
The psychics were to be investigated by a
committee from the Scientific American publication.
One of the mediums under the lens was well-known
spiritualist Mina Crandon, known as ‘Margery’.
Margery attempted to seduce several members
of the Committee to secure the prize, and
she even made a pass at Harry.
Houdini was not easily charmed, as he said
of her
‘Her applesauce means nothing to me’
Houdini’s crusade culminated in 1926, when
he testified before the US Congress in support
of a bill to outlaw the practice of “pretending
to tell fortunes for reward or compensation”.
The bill was made into law, albeit only in
the District of Columbia.
I should clarify now that Houdini’s debunking
efforts were not entirely based on pure scepticism.
In fact, Harry did believe in a spiritual
world, he simply did not trust charlatans
who could claim access to it.
His belief in a Thereafter was put to the
test by an experience which involved one of
his dearest friends, Sir Arthur Conan Doyle.
Sir Arthur’s main creation Sherlock Holmes
was a paladin for rational thinking, and yet
the author firmly believed that the dead could
talk to the living.
Lady Doyle shared this belief and had a reputation
for being an accomplished medium.
In 1922 Sir Arthur and Lady Conan Doyle organised
for Houdini an automatic writing seance that
supposedly contacted his beloved mother Cecilia,
who had died nine years earlier.
Cecilia’s spirit convincingly took control
of Lady Doyle’s body – but Houdini was
not easily fooled.
Why did the wife of a Rabbi do the sign of
the cross?
Why a Hungarian immigrant who never learned
English, suddenly was writing in that language?
This seance was the beginning of the end of
Houdini's friendship with Sir Arthur Conan
Doyle – and may have fuelled his animosity
towards mediums.
Halloween, 1926[TA14]
While touring in Montreal, Canada, Houdini
was visited by two students of McGill University
in his dressing room.
It was the 22nd of October 1926.
One of them, J. Gordon Whitehead, asked Harry
if he could really absorb any punch to the
stomach.
Harry replied that yes, he could, and the
student suddenly punched him four times, probably
having misunderstood the reply as an invitation
to do so.
Houdini had terrible stomach pain for two
days, before finally seeing a doctor.
Harry was found to have a high fever and acute
appendicitis.
He was advised to go to the hospital for surgery,
but he preferred to go on stage and complete
his show.
But by the middle of the third act, Houdini
lowered the curtain and collapsed.
Bess and Dash had him taken to the hospital
where his appendix was removed.
But it was too late: it had already ruptured.
On October 31 – Halloween – 1926, Harry
Houdini died, Bess and Dash at his bedside.
The official cause of death: acute peritonitis,
caused by the appendix being ruptured by an
ill-timed punch.
You may have heard the theory that Houdini
was actually the victim of a spiritualist
conspiracy, but of course there is no evidence
of that.
Houdini's funeral was held on November 4,
1926 in New York with more than 2,000 mourners
in attendance.
In the years that followed Bess held annual
séances every Halloween to contact Harry.
The last séance took place exactly 10 years
after Harry’s death, and it was broadcast
over the radio.
After over an hour of silence Mrs. Houdini
decided to end the experiment, as Harry’s
spirit would just remain silent.
As the séance came to an end, a violent thunderstorm
broke out.
The participants, sitting on a hotel roof
top terrace were drenched by the violent rainfall,
while lighting set the sky ablaze.
They would later learn that the storm did
not occur anywhere else in the area - only
above the séance location.
I would not be surprised to learn if this
was Harry’s final stunt to wow yet another
audience and say goodbye - with a bang! – to
his beloved Bess.